back today Las Vegas Metro Police  Department hosted its second annual  Halloween dog parade at the Dollar Loan  Center the event featured a K-9 costume  contest and a few humans joined in on  the fun as well as you can see proceeds  from the event went to benefit both  active and retired dogs in Metro's K-9  unit  when our dogs retire they go home with  the Handler and they have a lot of  Medical Care usually so the lvmpd  foundation covers that medical care for  us and events like this is what keeps  that going  the dogs were ranked in categories Top  Dog best pack and top dog and human  award for more on how you can support  Metro's K-9 unit head to our website  8newsnow.com they all look great